on Thursday September 7th of 2023
hurricane Lee redefined what it means
for a storm to rapidly intensify
beginning in the North Atlantic and
moving steadily towards the Caribbean
islands Lee strengthened from a category
1 storm to a category 5 storm in a span
of just 24 hours in the past scientists
considered a storm to rapidly intensify
if it sustained winds increased by 35
miles or 56 kilometers per hour in 24
hours but over the course of one day
hurricane Lee increased by 80 miles or
129 kilometers per hour over double what
is considered a startling increase this
made Lee the third fastest intensifying
Atlantic hurricane on record
Lee was the first Category 5 hurricane
of the 2023 season its wind speed soon
went back down causing the storm to
fluctuate between Category 3 and 4. but
the significance of this storm's
Behavior remains storms are getting
bigger doing so more quickly and there
seems to be more of them than ever in
some recent years there were so many
storms that forecasters ran out of names
and had to resort to backup lists in
2020 there were a record 30 named storms
at the time of writing this so far in
this year's Atlantic hurricane season
there have been 13 named storms and five
full-blown hurricanes many of them
happening at the same time right now
hurricane Lee and hurricane Margot are
both tangoing in the Atlantic each
creating massive waves winds and
rainfall if you live in a coastal area
this is all alarming enough but there is
another question that all of these
storms happening at the same time brings
up what are the factors that can turn
these storms from a regular storm to a
city destroying Nightmare and as our
oceans warm and more storms form every
day there is perhaps an even more
terrifying thought can these hurricanes
even combine to create one world
altering hurricane how big were the
biggest Cyclones in history and should
we be bracing ourselves for more of
these gigantic storms
[Music]
hurricane is just one of the many names
given to these brutal storms the
official term is tropical cyclone and as
the name suggests they all form over the
tropics in these regions near the
equator ocean temperatures reach at
least 26 degrees Celsius these high
temperatures along with winds blowing
across the ocean cause the water to
evaporate this creates warm moist air
that rises High into the atmosphere
where it forms big storm clouds this
cycle repeats as new cooler air fills in
the space above the hot water then warms
and Rises as well the rotation of the
Earth causes the strengthening system to
spin once the spinning winds reach 118
kilometers per hour the storm is
classified as a tropical Cyclone on
average they can grow to a diameter of
nearly 500 kilometers but there have
been some record-setting Cyclones that
have grown to thousands of kilometers
wide but the anatomy of a tropical
Cyclone is a lot more intricate than
most images suggest there is a lot going
on below the clouds the center where the
warm air is rising and cool air is
falling is known as the eye of the storm
here it's calm with wind speeds staying
below 24 kilometers per hour it's also
clear as the moving air suppresses cloud
formation
but just outside of the eye it could not
be more different this is called the eye
wall in this ring of clouds are heavy
rains and the strongest Winds of cyclone
beyond the eye wall are the rain bands
these are bands of clouds that spiral
out from the center you can see their
characteristic pinwheel shape in radar
images as their name suggests they often
release rain but they can also produce
tornadoes finally resting on top of the
eye wall and Rain bands is the dense
cloud cover but without moist heat from
the warm tropical oceans even the most
powerful tropical Cyclone will break
down this is why they quickly weaken and
slow down when they travel over land
meet dry winds or move outside of the
tropics over colder water however it can
take some time before they fully
dissipate even over dry land and in the
meantime there are strong winds and rain
can wreak havoc on homes and businesses
along the path many tropical Cyclones
travel out of the tropics and become
mid-latitude Cyclones when they do they
undergo what's called an extra tropical
transition lacking the necessary warm
temperatures to maintain their
symmetrical pinwheel shape the cyclone
disarranges and spreads out forming more
of a camo-like shape these extra
tropical storms are common in the West
Pacific and North Atlantic oceans and
although they are no longer technically
a hurricane they can still generate lots
of rainfall large waves and even
hurricane-like winds which may be why we
often still refer to them as hurricanes
for instance Hurricane Sandy which
struck New Jersey and New York in 2012
transitioned into a mid-latitude cyclone
just before it hit but even so its wind
speed reached 145 kilometers per hour
overall Sandy devastated the East Coast
causing 70 billion dollars in Damages
destroying 650
000 homes and killing 72 people but
while its effects were truly horrific
it's a far cry from the biggest and most
destructive tropical Cyclones in history
in October of 1979 a disturbance in the
weather was reported near Micronesia
monsoons in this area are common at that
time of year so at first this was
nothing out of the ordinary but then
three separate storms began to form at
the same time at first these storms
competed with each other preventing any
significant growth but soon they were
each strong enough to become named
typhoons and then something remarkable
happened the outflow from the
easternmost storm storm Roger started to
Veer towards the central typhoon typhoon
tip this would become the fuel that
would allow typhoon tip to become the
largest most intense storm ever recorded
on earth
soon typhoon tip grew to a diameter of
over 2 000 kilometers which is about
half the size of the United States its
wind speeds reached a whopping 306
kilometers per hour its Central pressure
which is an indication of the strength
of the storm where lower values
correspond to a stronger storm dropped
to 870 millibars the lowest sea pressure
ever recorded in a storm luckily by the
time it made landfall on the Japanese
island of Honshu on October 19th it had
substantially weakened and soon
dissipated on October 22nd
even so it produced enough rain to cause
over 600 mudslides flood over 22 000
homes destroyed 27 Bridges and 105 dikes
and killed 99 people what happened with
Typhoon tip was an incredible instance
of a smaller storm fueling a bigger one
but could typhoon tip have become even
larger if the two storms fully combined
on September 1st 2022 Category 5 typhoon
hinem Noor the strongest tropical
Cyclone of that year was barreling
towards Taiwan from the Western Pacific
Ocean at the same time a tropical storm
named gardo was traveling in this same
direction as the two storms got close to
each other something strange happened
they started to swirl around one another
until hinam Noor completely devoured
gardo this was a textbook example of a
phenomenon known as the fujiwara effect
however when one storm devours another
its intensity doesn't always increase in
this case hinam noor's intensity
actually decreased but as our oceans
continued to get hotter a merger between
two large enough tropical Cyclones could
lead to the formation of a mega Cyclone
causing utter Devastation but what's
more likely to happen when two storms
get close to one another is not that
they merge and become one Mega storm but
that their paths become completely
unpredictable this is what happened in
the case of typhoon's Parma and malor in
2009. the interaction of these storms
caused Parma to gain strength and make
several u-turns and become stagnant over
the Luzon region of the Philippines this
erratic Behavior also prevented
scientists from being able to provide
people with the early warning that they
would need to get themselves to safety
but storms don't need to interact to
become record-breaking monsters
currently the longest live tropical
Cyclone is Freddy which occurred earlier
this year unlike most tropical Cyclones
Freddie took an interesting path
traveling over 8 000 kilometers it
formed on February 3rd just Northwest of
Australia traveled across the entire
Indian Ocean and made landfall on the
eastern coast of Madagascar on February
21st then it traveled across the
Mozambique Channel where it made
landfall in Mozambique on February 24th
before traveling back into the channel
circling around and then making landfall
again in Mozambique on March 11th where
it finally dissipated
overall it lasted 36 Days across these
regions Freddy caused massive damage and
took the lives of over 300 people but
despite its longevity this was nowhere
near the deadliest tropical Cyclone that
took place in 1970 on the coast of
Bangladesh with a death toll of an
estimated 500
000 people and some estimates are even
higher this was the great bowl of
cyclone and it made landfall in what was
then East Pakistan from November 12th to
the 13th while wind speeds were lower
than both Cyclone Freddy and typhoon tip
reaching 225 kilometers per hour and
Central pressure dropped to just 950
millibars the high number of fatalities
was a direct result of the geography of
this region Bangladesh is densely
populated consisting of low-lying
islands and tidal Flats about 35 of the
area is less than six meters above sea
level and more than 20 percent of the
country experiences yearly flooding in
addition the coast is shaped in a way
that funnels in Cyclones from the Bay of
Bengal to make matters worse
communication with most people living
along the coast and on the islands was
impossible so while meteorologists knew
of the incoming Cyclone they had no way
to warn and Evacuate the area but this
was just one major storm in a series of
devastating weather events that have
impacted this region in fact seven of
the nine deadliest weather events of the
20th century were tropical Cyclones that
struck Bangladesh more recently in 1991
another severe Cyclone made landfall in
the area drowning 140 000 people this
number could have been much higher but
thankfully warning and evacuation
systems were in place allowing for
several million people to be evacuated
ahead of time and as storms batter the
coast this time of year there is a
pervasive narrative that there are more
storms than ever and that they're
getting worse but is this true we know
that giant Cyclones have been a Scourge
for as long as humans have had records
are the storms now truly a result of
climate change
using satellite data scientists can
monitor the strength duration and
frequency of storms they can use this
information to analyze how the intensity
of tropical Cyclones has been changing
as our climate has warmed they do so
with two calculations that use wind
speed measurements and both have been
increasing data on tropical storms in
the North Atlantic have shown that the
total accumulated Cyclone energy index
has been significantly above the normal
threshold since the mid 90s and the
power dissipation index has pretty much
followed the rising sea surface
temperatures caused by global warming
but this hasn't necessarily led to an
increase in the frequency of tropical
Cyclones though it's hard to say for
sure there have been a lot of changes in
weather collection technology over the
years for instance aircraft data
collection began in only 1944 and
satellite tracking started in 1966. this
makes it difficult to know the exact
number of tropical Cyclones that have
happened before we had these
capabilities and those that never
impacted any humans either at sea or on
land would have gone unnoticed however
while determining the exact amount of
cyclones that we never noticed may be
nearly impossible scientists have found
a way to estimate it in a study
published in 2010 researchers used ship
traffic records of boats traveling in
the North Atlantic Ocean during the
pre-satellite years based on the
trajectory and any alterations to their
route the researchers approximated the
number of missing tropical Cyclones in
the record and analyzed how the
frequency changed each year overall they
found that the number of annual tropical
Cyclones is not increasing and that
there have been no significant changes
over time but while the frequency may
not be increasing the strength and
duration of these Cyclones definitely
are that's because warmer water means
more fuel for these storms in a study
evaluating the intensity of tropical
Cyclones over the last 39 years
researchers found that the number of
major Cyclones increases by about 10
percent from 1988 to 2007 or about 5
Each decade while the number of minor
ones is decreasing looking forward
computer models predict that in just the
next few decades tropical Cyclones will
be 24 wetter have 13 percent stronger
winds and be 17 percent slower
altogether this amasses two powerful
lingering Cyclones capable of dumping
massive amounts of water in one area as
well as giving the strong winds more
time to assault buildings and trees
while these are just predictions one
thing that we know for sure is that sea
levels are rising since 1900 the average
sea level has risen over 15 centimeters
and it's expected to continue to
increase for at least another 30 by the
end of this Century this increases the
risk of flooding along coastal regions
we've already seen how this has
intensified the impact of recent
tropical Cyclones such as Hurricane
Katrina in 2005. a study published in
2014 estimated that flood elevations
experienced during the Cyclone were 15
to 60 percent higher than they would
have been in 1900. this equals 0.8 to
2.4 meters of water because of all of
this scientists are working on better
forecasts that won't only tell us
details on the characteristics of a
storm but what types of Damages it will
create and how it will impact a
community this will help develop better
Warning Systems and improve the planning
of evacuations because as the earth's
climate gets hotter there's a big chance
that the most severe storms are yet to
come to me sometimes it feels like
predicting the weather is basically
Magic
how can they know that a particular
hurricane is going to make a hard right
turn or that the weather 10 days from
now is going to cool off and yet
forecasters usually get it more or less
right imagine telling your ancestors
about this ability we can literally tell
the future at least in this one specific
domain it might feel like magic but
weather forecasts are actually made by
collecting data about the current state
of the atmosphere and using an
understanding of atmospheric processes
to predict how the atmosphere will
evolve its data and its probability
these are some of the most powerful
tools that the world of mathematics
gives us and surprisingly there is a
free and easy way to learn more about
them
brilliant.org has so many courses on
subjects just like this and it's the
best way to learn math data science and
computer science interactively I've
always struggled with lectures and
textbooks but brilliant is an
Interactive Learning environment where
less are structured around things that
feel more like games and puzzles than
like college coursework there are levers
sliders and buttons so you can test
theories and visualize high level Math
and Science Concepts the exploring data
visually course has been particularly
helpful in visualizing Concepts that can
be otherwise hard to wrap your head
around lessons within this course like
the filtering data lesson teaches you to
toggle different filters to understand
the best way to visualize the data
you're working with or there's the
predicting probability course that
teaches you how to harness data to
predict future outcomes in adult life we
are constantly making decisions so so so
many decisions and understanding
probability can really help you feel
more competent and confident in the
choices that you make from choosing an
airline while traveling to investing to
planning an outdoor event brilliant has
thousands of lessons like this from
foundational and advanced math to AI to
data science and neural networks and
more with new lessons added monthly so
to better learn how to confidently
navigate this world of overwhelming
numbers and to try everything that
brilliant has to offer free for a full
30 days visit brilliant.org real science
or click on the link in the description
the first 200 people will get 20 off
Brilliance annual premium subscription
and every sign up helps this channel